[Applauso]
[Musica]
un anno fa circa mi trovavo con la mia
fidanzata federica a parigi in un
ristorante uno di quei ristoranti
romantici con la luce soffusa e stavamo
cenando ed eravamo seduti nel ristorante
nel tavolo del ristorante più lontano
rispetto alla porta d'ingresso
io sono il classico tipo un po paranoico
che si che controlla tutto e serva
sempre tutto sono il classico che magari
mentre sta cenando cerca di capire se il
tizio al tavolo accanto è un potenziale
serial killer o meno
durante la cena all'improvviso entrano
nel ristorante due persone un ragazzo e
una ragazza visibilmente alterati
forse avevano preso sostanze erano solo
molto molto ubriachi iniziano a fare un
po di caciara uno dei due si accascia a
terra il titolare del ristorante si
avvicina subito insieme un cameriere li
accompagnano all'uscita questa scena
dura pochi secondi
probabilmente il resto del ristorante
non se n'è accorto il titolare stesso in
pochi secondi è riuscito a tirarli fuori
nel momento in cui li ha mandati via io
mi sono alzato e sono corso fuori verso
di loro li ho rincorsi e sono riuscito
così a recuperare la borsa della
fidanzata che avevano rubato e altre due
tre borse qualche cappotto questo perché
in quel secondo in cui la persona si era
accasciata era riuscita a arraffare dei
cappotti e delle borse che erano vicini
alla porta d'ingresso mentre la
fidanzata cercava di distrarre del
titolare il cameriere probabilmente il
titolare che aveva a che fare con loro
non si era reso conto di questa cosa
perché non aveva fiducia nel loro stato
alterato era quella la sua
preoccupazione il resto del ristorante
non se n'era neanche accorto
io in quella occasione non avevo fiducia
nel genere umano
nel senso che mi hanno ricordato che il
cameriere aveva portato le borse i
cappotti vicino in uno sgabuzzino molto
vicino alla porta
in quell'occasione non avevo creduto
allo stato alterato delle persone avevo
creduto un passo prima proprio di una
mancanza di fiducia nei loro confronti
del fatto che fosse una scusa per
derubarci per fortuna sono riuscito a
recuperare le borse e per fortuna non mi
sento neanche tanto strano perché il
problema della fiducia nella civiltà
umana in problema che noi ci portiamo
dietro da circa 10.000 anni
pensate e non è sempre stato così non
siamo nati senza la mancanza di fiducia
e solo negli ultimi dieci anni che
l'essere umano non si fida più
dell'essere umano
se torniamo a 10.000 anni fa infatti
agli inizi della civiltà per quel poco
che ce ne era la nostra economia di base
si basava sull'economia del dono
ognuno di noi produceva un top consumava
una frazione di quello che produceva e
tutto quello che avanzava lo regalava lo
regalava che gli stava intorno a chi
incontrava chi viveva con lui ea sua
volta riceveva in regalo quello che
capitava che veniva prodotto dalle altre
popolazioni intorno e questo andava bene
nessuno attribuiva un valore al suo
lavoro a quello che produceva quello che
regola anche qualche regalava e nessuno
pretendeva di avere per forza qualcosa
in cambio
poi dopo qualche migliaio di anni
abbiamo avuto bisogno di inventarci il
baratto una delle forme primordiali di
scambio di valore perché perché eravamo
tanti e io sì regalavo quello che mi
avanzava ma non avevo più la certezza
che avrei ricevuto qualcosa in cambio e
quindi abbiamo dovuto dare un valore a
quello che scambiavamo i problemi del
baratto brevemente sono stati tanti
spesso venivano barattati bestiale cibo
quindi a da deperibile spesso non
frazionabile quindi era molto difficile
barattare con popolazioni che abitavano
distanti e allora si sono inventati le
prime forme di pre moneta hanno dovuto
abbiamo dovuto come civiltà
standardizzare il valore che ci
scambiavamo non avevamo le monete come
l'immaginiamo oggi avevamo probabilmente
gli oggetti che più utilizzavamo in base
alle alle alle aree geografiche in cui
scambiavamo valore quindi i sassi il
sale plagiata e così via
immaginatevi però trasportare enormi
quantità di sassi per andare a fare la
spesa e immaginatevi il problema con il
sasso ha un peso diverso una dimensione
diversa e quindi per me questi sassi
valgono un totem a perché deve vendermi
quel bene non valgono lo stesso
eccoli la grande intuizione ce l'hanno
avuta e santuari il commercio l'hanno
inventato santuario non l'hanno
inventato i mercanti i santuari hanno
capito che c'era un enorme problema di
fiducia alla base e si sono messi come
terza parte fiducia re come
intermediario fiduciario sono diventati
garanti di quella moneta qualsiasi
moneta qualsiasi sasso che passasse
sotto i santuari veniva marchiato ai
santuari in attribuivano un valore e ne
mette volune
il marchio che diceva era passato qui
quindi quel valore era giusto ea nessuno
importava più controllare quel valore
poteva non essere realmente quel peso
quel valore poteva non valere nulla ma
se sopra c'era un marchio quindi una
terza parte garante che non aveva nulla
a che fare in quello scambio che
attribuiva quel valore allora a tutti le
credevano perché tutti l'avrebbero
accettato e se ci pensate questo va bene
ancora oggi
oggi quei santuari sono diventati le
banche i sistemi di pagamento tutti
quegli intermediari fiduciari che in
altri sistemi non per forza finanziati
possiamo chiamare il notaio chiunque
deve apporre una garanzia di fiducia tra
due persone io non posso comprare o
vendere la mia casa con un altra persona
se non c'è un notaio e lo registra da
qualche parte come io non posso se vengo
interrogato a scuola decidere che voto
mettermi deve esserci un professore e lo
stato l'università la scuola si fida di
quello che dice il professore non di
quello che dice l'alunno è forse il
grande problema nostro e che per 10.000
anni abbiamo creduto per risolto il
problema della fiducia che non ci siamo
più preoccupati di risolverlo realmente
in realtà il problema della fiducia non
è risolto perché quel quel garante
quella terza parte fiduciaria ha un
costo impiega del tempo a garantire un
qualcosa ma la cosa più pericolosa e che
può sbagliarsi o in cattiva fede può
essere corrotto per sbagliarsi
e allora arriviamo così un po più avanti
al 1400 pensate nel 1400 il problema lo
avevano risolto ma non abbiamo dato
troppo peso nel 1400 e qui arriva la
storia di questo oggetto particolarmente
strano questo oggetto è un rai è un
sasso nel 1400 in un'isola in una
sperduta isola microscopica in micro
nese l'isola di yap indigeni gli
abitanti decidono un giorno di salire
sulle loro zattere e vedere cosa c'è
oltre l'oceano si fanno più di 400 km
arrivano alla terraferma più vicina
palau e li trovano oggetti alberi frutti
cosa che non avevano sulla loro isola
perché è la misura molto piccola tra le
tante cose si innamorano particolarmente
di queste formazioni calcaree ovviamente
questo è riprodotto ora vi spiegherò
perché di queste formazioni calcaree che
non sono altro che sassi con un buco al
centro ma piacciono talmente tanto
questi sassi che iniziano a fare
spedizioni per portarli
sulla loro isola nell'isola viene
ricoperta di questi sassi e allora pochi
anni più avanti iniziano ad avere il
bisogno di avere loro un modo per
standardizzare il valore di avere loro
bisogno di una moneta che non avevano
fino a quel momento
essi chiedono qual è l'oggetto che
abbiamo più grande quantità sull'isola
il rai
usiamo in rai come moneta e attenzione
perché qui cambia tutto quello che
avviene nell'isola di iab è totalmente
diverso da quello che avviene nel resto
della civiltà umana non danno un valore
in base a ciò con cui è costruito e rai
oa ciò che si dice su raid hanno un
valore in base alla sua storia ogni
singolo sasso in base alla storia che ha
può valere di più o di meno se il salso
e piccolo ed è stato facilmente
trasportato ho raccolto pare poco se il
sasso è molto grande e sono morte delle
persone in quella spedizione per
riuscire a portarlo nella loro isola
allora vale tantissimo e quindi
probabilmente lui abitanti più ricchi
dell'isola avevano i sassi più grandi
spesso molti sassi il dato che persone
erano morte per trasportarli si
trovavano in fondo all'oceano
ma non importava a vederlo o possederlo
fisicamente
qualcuno aveva tramontato quella storia
qualcuno aveva raccontato che 10 persone
erano morte in mezzo all'oceano per
trasportare un sasso di 10 metri
quadrati di un diametro di 10 metri e
allora quel sasso valeva proprio tanto
anche se non lo vedevamo ci fidavamo di
quello che c'era stato tramandato il
problema sorge quando chi deteneva tanti
sassi non li poteva tenere dentro la
propria abitazione e magari la notte lì
venivano rubati e lì avviene una seconda
idea geniale hanno una secondaria
geniale oggi nel 2019 quel il problema
del del furto della fiducia come lo
risolveremo probabilmente utilizzeremo
tutti i sassi che ci sono rimasti per
pagare qualcuno che faccia la guardi al
nulla o andremo noi a nostra volta a
rubare di nascosto a qualcun altro
perché qualcuno ha rubato a me quindi
sono giustificato nel 1400 per fortuna
erano più intelligenti di noi nel 2019 e
inventano una legge applicano un codice
di regolamento ogni singolo abitante
deve avere un registro condiviso deve
avere una mattonella non so anche
materiale fosse fatto ma ogni singolo
abitante aveva una
di un registro unico decentralizzato che
riportava tutte le informazioni sulle
proprietà dei sassi e non importava più
che se l'avessero rubata o meno che quel
sasso esistesse veramente un occhio e tu
lo avessi in mano per spenderlo bastava
che la tua informazione fosse
all'interno di quel registro se attuale
il problema di quel sasso in fondo
all'oceano lo volevi spendere andare a
spenderlo senza portartelo dietro senza
dover andare a recuperarlo in mezzo
all'oceano qualcuno dall'altra parte
avrebbe controllato registro e avrebbe
trovato la tua proprietà il grande val
grande cambio di paradigma è che il
valore non è più intrinseco in qualcosa
ma già non lo è più neanche oggi ma il
valore nell'informazione
nell'informazione che da sola non basta
nell'informazione condivisa da tutte le
persone che contribuiscono che fanno
parte di quella rete
ecco questa è roba che ti ho spiegato è
che io ho voluto costruire con le mie
mani perché vi avrei potuto far vedere
una foto su internet che scrivete rai
l'isola di yap più appare qualsiasi foto
lo avrei potuto fare una slide ma
costruendo la a un altro valore perché
un'altra storia
ci ho messo cinque giorni è stato un
problema costruirla però a un altro
valore
ecco oggi dopo 600 anni non abbiamo
ancora capito
oggi dopo 600 anni abbiamo una seconda
possibilità però stiamo rivivendo quella
storia perché esiste una tecnologia che
si chiama block chain scatena di blocchi
che non è altro che cosa non è altro che
un database distribuito decentralizzato
e condiviso tra i partecipanti di una
rete con la differenza che è applicata
tecnologia che abbiamo oggi la stessa
identica cosa che nel 1400 si erano
inventati con i fatti perché solo sassi
avevano oggi noi siamo inventati con la
crittografia coi computer perché sono
quelli sassi di oggi è lì che girano le
informazioni di oggi ma il problema qual
è il problema è che dopo 600 anni ci
siamo accorti che questa roba forse
funziona
abbiamo perso già 600 anni e tuttora
stiamo perdendo tempo
pensate che per farvi un esempio per
farvi capire quanto esponenzialmente
accelerata lo sviluppo della tecnologia
se vi dovesse dire qualche prodotto
tecnologico degli ultimi anni tiple
aeroplano lo sapete quanto ci ha messo a
diffondersi l'aeroplano più di 60 anni e
l'elettricità elettricità di cui senza
quel oggi non potremmo vivere 40 anni 40
anni persi e i computer
anzi la tv la tv la tv ha messo
vent'anni i computer una decina di anni
notate qualcosa ogni passo evolutivo è
sempre più veloce sempre più celere più
accelerato
poi c'è un problema lo sapete qual è il
prodotto tecnologico innovativo
chiamatelo come volete che ci ha messo
il minor tempo per diffondersi a
raggiungere dai 50 ai 100 milioni di
persone in soli 19 giorni
poche mongomo qualcosa non sta
funzionando
probabilmente c'è qualcosa che non va
forse la colpa è nostra
forse stiamo costruendo sempre più
tecnologia a misura d uomo e ci stiamo
dimenticando di formare quegli uomini a
misura di quelle tecnologie
forse oggi stiamo insegnando tramandando
stiamo dicendo i nostri figli cose che
andavano bene 50 anni fa stiamo
insegnando loro materie per lavori che
esistevano 50 anni fa lo stiamo dicendo
loro cosa esisterà fra 50 anni
non stiamo spiegando loro perché fra 50
anni il notaio che già nella maggior
parte dei paesi mondiali non esiste più
certamente non esisterà più
anzi che stiamo incitando a studiare per
diventare notai e dopo aver studiato
tanto dopo tanti anni se poi non si
trovano il lavoro per cui hanno studiato
da un problema e questo è un problema di
fiducia e oggi abbiamo un'opportunità
incredibile per la seconda volta nella
storia e la prima capite bene che non
l'abbiamo colta tanto bene piccola
parentesi fino a qualche anno fa l'isola
di yap quindi in tempi moderni ancora
utilizzava questo sistema e non si è mai
lamentato nessuno
ecco oggi noi continuiamo ad andare
avanti col progresso tecnologico
mandiamo decappottabili nello spazio
e poi non risolviamo il problema dei
furti di auto qui sulla terra non
risolviamo il problema degli esseri
umani che ci abitano accanto ancora
siamo costretti a venire ad una
conferenza
tenerci la borsa o lozano stretta vicino
perché non possiamo lasciarla
incustodita
questo forse è la grande sfida
dell'umanità e forse dobbiamo ripartire
da qui forse dobbiamo tornare indietro
di 600 anni perché oggi non è più pesce
grande che mangia pesce piccolo
oggi e pesce e veloce che mangia pesce
lento e la velocità a cui questa
innovazione sta andando e incredibile e
non ci aspetta non ha motivo di
aspettarci c'è mentre ci lamentiamo che
domani avremo 800 milioni di robot che
ci ruberanno il lavoro dall'altra parte
del mondo
i paesi che chiamiamo terzo mondo stanno
costruendo quei robot che stanno
studiando noi no noi continuiamo a
studiare ea insegnare a tramandare
lavori che già oggi non esistono più che
già oggi hanno hanno problema ad
affermarsi oa trovare spazio nel mondo
del lavoro e questo è un problema enorme
allora se torniamo alla blog chain
se torniamo a quella decentralizzazione
a quel registro distribuito a quella
crittografia che ci permette di
certificare e tracciare in maniera
immutabile le informazioni
pensate alla possibilità di applicarla a
tutti gli altri nostri sistemi
immaginatevi le nostre tasse pagate
attraverso la blog cei il nostro stato
avrebbe un privilegio incredibile
potrebbe usufruire dei nostri soldi in
tempo reale e noi potremmo vedere in
tempo reale ogni singola nostro
centesimo sebbene realmente spesa per il
servizio che stiamo pagando allora non
potremo più lamentarci delle tasse
perché in quel caso non è colpa delle
tasse colpa di noi non siamo degni di
essere i cittadini che immaginiamo alla
beneficenza la possibilità di donare
soldi con la blow cena in tempo reale a
chi si trova realmente nell'epicentro di
un terremoto non a chi ha la quinta casa
di vacanze si deve rifare la villa no e
chi veramente in difficoltà ha perso
tutto può soffrire di quei soldi in
tempo reale non deve aspettare anni che
gli sms prima o poi arriveranno ve lo
promettiamo meno il 40 per cento di
commissioni no li userà subito allora
ripartiamo da copie prego perché questo
ci insegna una cosa importante ci
insegna che la storia di chi siamo noi
il nostro passato ci dal valore ci
insegna un'altra cosa che se ci
guardiamo intorno che siamo noi oggi il
nostro presente
ci può ridare una ripartenza indicarci
la strada ma quello che manca è avere
fede incrollabile fede nel futuro perché
la blow chain funziona solo se siamo
tutti d'accordo e pensate quanto siamo
forti se ci mettiamo tutti d'accordo
grazie
[Applauso]